you never know what's gonna cause the
next great discovery to be made
is it a Eureka moment in the middle of
the night is it some small small ink
consistency and a measurement that you
made
Isaac Asimov famously noted that the
greatest discoveries in the history of
the world weren't somebody burning the
midnight oil saying Eureka it was
somebody looking at some data and saying
that's odd so consider that in the late
1800s classical physics was riding high
what does classical physics it's Newton
it's it's its electricity its magnetism
it's all of these sort of basic laws of
physics that were established basically
between the 1600s and the 1800s all
right definitely before the quantum and
before relativity and all these exotic
theories of the universe that defy every
bit of common sense you could possibly
bring to bear so there's some well-known
scientists at the end of the 1800s and
they were sure that there were no more
major discoveries to take place in the
field and that physics would soon end
they were just a few messy clouds on the
horizon that some better research would
resolve which leads to they don't these
differ from each other do the experiment
again a few times and that'll all come
out just fine coming out of the 1800s
however those small clouds turned to be
more like they're not to be more like
sort of chinks in the armor of classical
physics which eventually opened a door
into a century of mind-blowing modern
physics that transformed the world not
only the world in physics but
geopolitics as well it's a simple
introduction of e equals MC squared as
the foundation of all our nuclear
arsenals how they generate energy so
small things that don't quite work some
of them get resolved with better data
others don't they lead to deep and new
understandings of the universe and so in
that spirit I bring to you a story
something we call the Pioneer anomaly
there are two spacecraft pioneer 10 and
11 they were launched in 1972 in 1973
and they were destined to take a tour of
the planets and escape the solar system
altogether and the way you do that is
because we don't have our Rockets aren't
big enough to give it that much energy
so they launch and they swing behind
they come in behind a planet and they
fall towards it and the orbit of the
planet catches on to the to the space
probe and then you do a sort of a
gravitational slingshot flinging it
forward with extra energy when you do
that for a couple of planets you can
have enough energy to have those space
probe probes escape the solar system
altogether they were the first-ever
pieces of hardware to achieve this feat
and because of this fact we had a fixed
on their sides a famous plaque of
pictograms it showed among other things
an unclothed male and female human form
and the male you may remember this from
from the day and the male had an arm
raised presumably a sign of peace that
assumes that this is a sign of peace to
aliens of course but on this plaque
there's a map that showed where the
craft came from which is essentially the
return address of the solar system in
the galaxy and not only that it showed
some other basic scientific insights
that we've gleaned as a species so all
of this is in case the aliens from
another star system found the craft it
would allow them to learn basic facts
about our species hum reminds hit there
was a comic shortly after the spacecraft
did their thing and they were well
publicized there was a comic and it
showed aliens
who had captured come upon the pion
aircraft and they're looking at this
picture that we sent on the side of the
craft and these aliens are dressed in
tuxedos by the way and one alien turns
to the other and says they're just like
us except they don't wear clothes stupid
comic but I'd never forget it but anyway
these plaques represented the first-ever
attempt to communicate with another
species using pictograms and hardware
that they might come upon now here they
are on their way out of the solar system
we expect them to slow down we know
they're going to escape but whatever
speed they have we expect them to slow
down as they climb out of the Sun's
gravitational embrace now since they
have enough energy to escape entirely
they'll slow down but never slow down to
zero okay that's fine here's the problem
the actual deceleration we measure is
greater for each craft then what we
calculate it should be after accounting
for all the possible forces that could
slow down the craft that is the Pioneer
anomaly the effect is small but it's
persistent and every attempt to
understand its cause has failed the
effect became measurable about eight
years into the journey but it was not
studied in detail until about 1994 and
we haven't communicated with the pioneer
craft since 2003 they're too far away
now for signals to be exchanged but we
have data over a 23-year period from
nineteen from 1980 right on up through
night through 2003 and that baseline of
data continues to be studied now
consider we've never before measured the
force of gravity in the solar system
with such precision over such
distances for such a long period of time
so this constitutes a new experimental
frontier in physics if you perform an
experiment that's never been performed
before you almost expect something new
to show up you expect it because no one
has done it before it's a it's it's
looking in a place you would never had
the occasion to look to understand the
behavior of nature all right
so what's it cause here is the Sun
misbehaving first you blame the
engineers that's what I would do
blame the engineers it's like look have
you looked at all the possible onboard
sources of what could interfere with the
acceleration of this craft okay have you
looked at any possible sort of
outgassing of fuel cells or fuel tanks
or double-check triple-check
bring in the designer of the craft do
you have a model of it here let's check
that okay all of this has been done all
of this has been done and all those
sources of errors have been removed
we're pretty sure okay so we ask
ourselves has this experiment found the
limits of our current theories of
gravity and motion or is there still
some engineering problem that even the
designers of the craft have not figured
out yet what we know is that this
problem exists for both pioneers and
they're not headed in the same direction
there are like 90-degree angles to one
another they both have this extra
deceleration the Pioneer anomaly remains
unsolved to this day do we know do we
know if
will ever be solved because there's not
another experiment right now ready to
double-check it we're kind of stuck with
these data for now but I can tell you if
it never gets solved and it is an
anomaly this is a piece of piece of
information that we're gonna have to
hold on to not dust it under the rug not
just keep blaming the engineers at some
point you have to blame nature and when
you get enough of those occasions where
where nature is misbehaving you know
it's time to come up with a new theory
of the universe and that might just be
what awaits us you know
85% of all the gravity we measure in the
universe comes from a source about which
we know nothing we call it dark matter
but since we're fundamentally clueless
but what it is okay the dark matter is
just a placeholder name all right we
could easily have just called it Fred
all right in both cases we don't know
what it is that's causing it all right
we have no idea dark matter was
discovered in 1933 it's been around for
a while was discovered by an irascible
astrophysicist named Fritz Zwicky he was
Swiss born but spent most of his
professional life in America in fact at
Caltech in Pasadena California what he
did was he studied a large cluster of
galaxies happens to be called the Coma
Cluster it has thousand galaxies in it
whole galaxies galaxies is a has itself
billions of stars so this is a massive
structure in the universe and all these
galaxies are bound together by their
mutual gravity and what he found
is that the speed that these galaxies
are moving within the cluster is faster
than the collective gravity of each
galaxy can sustain in other words at the
speeds he found them moving the galaxies
should have flown apart from one another
long ago but they're not they're bound
together they're still bound together
they didn't fly apart he proposed that
there's some missing mass that must lurk
somewhere within the cluster whose extra
gravity he was tracking now this result
turned out to be true for every single
cluster ever measured ever since
back then it was known as the missing
mass problem today we call it the Dark
Matter problem let's fast forward 1976
carnegie astrophysicists Vera Rubin she
was studying the rotation of spiral
galaxies we're a spiral galaxy in the
Milky Way and what she found is that
they were rotating faster than the known
mass within the galaxy should allow dark
matter it turned out was not a problem
unique to galaxy clusters it was a
problem that revealed itself even within
galaxies themselves could it be dark
clouds black holes dark planets anything
dark no no no and no if it
substance then it cannot be made of
anything familiar familiar materials
they absorb reflect refract and
otherwise interact with light and other
materials but this stuff doesn't
interact with anything at all not even
itself it only reveals itself to us
through its gravity it is a
fundamentally different thing going on
than any possible measurements that our
own familiar materials would reveal so
you could ask
could it be an undiscovered family of
particles that barely interact with our
kind of particles sure why not in fact
that's the odds-on favorite scenario and
top particle physicists today are
working on that could it be a failure in
our concept of gravity in other words do
we need a new theory of gravity to
account for it unlikely but we've got
top gravity theorists that are working
on that one too they call it Monde
modified Newtonian dynamics seems like
whatever is your specialty you think the
solution resides within your expertise
reminds me of the old adage if we were
hammers with the dark problem with with
the dark matter problem look like a nail
you know what my favorite possibility is
maybe the dark matter is the ordinary
matter of an 85-percent more massive
parallel universe influencing ours by
gravity leakage from one universe to
another I like that one if so it would
be the first evidence of other universes
and yet the evidence was there all along
you know dark matter is the longest
standing problem in modern astrophysics
and it persists to this day you know as
if one profound mystery of the universe
is not enough
recently dark matter was joined by dark
energy as one of the most profound
sources of ignorance the astrophysicist
faces today the late-1990s teams of
researchers led by saul paul murder
Brian Schmidt and Adam riess discovered
that the expanding universe itself
discovered by Edwin Hubble in the 1920s
was accelerating that turned out to be a
Nobel prize-winning measurement this
force that's making it accelerate we
call it dark energy but since we don't
actually know what it is we could just
as easily call it Barney all right
that's what I want Dark Matter I'll call
Fred dark energy Barney it doesn't
matter because they're just placeholder
words to accommodate our ignorance you
don't want to read too much into those
words so here's how it works
if the collective gravity of all the
galaxies in the universe were all there
was then the expansion of the universe
should be slowing down not speeding up
because gravity is an attractive force
resisting the expansion what we found is
that there's a mysterious pressure
operating in the vacuum of space and
it's combating the gravity and winning
we don't know its origin we don't know
what it is we're not even sure of its
long-term effects
turns out Albert Einstein after he
published his new theory of gravity in
1916 that's of course the general theory
of relativity he noticed that it
predicted a universe that should either
be contracting or expanding now that's
odd how could everything you know how
could how could the universe do
if it is everything this was a profound
scientific and philosophical dilemma
unthinkable concept and if it's
expanding or contracting compared with
what and so Einstein added a
mathematically legitimate term to his
equations that term allowed him to
stabilize the collapsing influence of
gravity in a way to hold up the universe
against its wishes and that way he could
keep the universe the same size whatever
size that was within just a few years
however after Edwin Hubble showed that
the universe was indeed expanding
Einstein rapidly withdrew the
stabilizing term from his equation you
know what he called it he called the
introduction of that term he's the
greatest blunder of my life he knew what
he felt deep inside that that term could
not be anything physical there's nothing
in the universe that repels matter not
on large scale magnet can do it but on
large scale there's no known thing that
could repel matter so this term that he
added to his equation he was very
uncomfortable about that
that's what left him to call it the
greatest blunder of my life turns out
the measurement and existence of dark
energy is precisely that term in his
equations what that term and his
equations do is exactly what we see dark
energy doing in the cosmos so in fact
Einsteins greatest blunder was saying
that the inclusion of that anti-gravity
term was as great as blunder isn't it
great to be so smart that you're right
even when you're wrong so here's what
you do you take the energy contained in
what we call dark energy and it's seven
percent of all that drives the universe
include with that percentage the dark
matter and we are driven to the humble
mind-blowing conclusion that 96% of all
that is the universe is not anything we
even remotely understand 96% and that
all of our laws of physics everything we
know love interact with and understand
or even can predict anything about the
future that falls into the 4% that
remains now actually it gets worse our
most successful theory of the universe
quantum physics allows you to calculate
what you might expect to be the energy
contained in the vacuum of space we can
do that calculation it allows it it
predicts that this should be energy
there all right we do the calculation
quantum physics has never been wrong
it's a it's our best understanding going
when you do that calculation the answer
you get does not match reality the
answer you get is off by a factor of 10
to the 20th power that's a one followed
by 120 zero now that's just embarrassing
I'm sorry all right we put forth our
best theory to our biggest problem and
it gets us nowhere in fact it is the
biggest mismatch between theory and
observation that there ever was in the
history of science that's our state
that's our state of the science today so
we are not only ignorant our best
theories of the universe can't guide us
so I think that means we're driving
blind if you add together so the three
kinds of things that occupy the universe
the familiar matter that's what we're
made of and what our telescopes detect
the dark matter that's the source of 85%
of all the gravity we see in the
universe and we don't know what's
causing it and the dark energy the stuff
that's making us accelerate against the
wishes of gravity each one of those
components creates a curvature of the
fabric of space and time just as
prescribed by Einstein's general theory
of relativity if you add those
curvatures together what you find is
that they create a universe that is
perfectly flat flat now that's not the
only shape the universe could have had
universe could have negative curvature
and if it did that would have us we have
a saddle shape and a negatively curved
universe has a net positive energy the
universe is neither spherical shape the
shape of a ball that would be positive
curvature having net negative energy now
another way to get insight into this is
to think about the energy of orbits an
object in orbit is gravitationally bound
to what it circles and bound orbits have
negative gravitational energy that's how
we describe this system increase the
elongation of the orbit by pumping
energy giving more speed to the object
and the circle distorts and becomes an
ellipse give it even more speed the
ellipse gets more and more elongated
there's just the right amount of energy
just the right amount of extra speed you
can give this object so that it goes so
far away it never circles back in fact
it escapes to infinity at that point
that object and the system and the
object that
orbiting object and the object around
which it formerly turned has zero total
gravitational energy and that path is
formally called a parabola give the
object even more energy then it gets to
infinity and keeps going that has net
positive energy and we call that
trajectory a hyperbola now you've
actually seen these shape before at home
take a flashlight all flashlights have a
cone of light that emerges from them if
you take in an aim it's straight out of
wall it'll make a perfect circle take it
and tip the angle just a bit that circle
distorts and you get an ellipse tip the
flashlight so it's parallel to the wall
and you'll see the shape on the wall and
we'll take the form of a parabola angle
it a little more it opens up even
further and you get a hyperbola try that
at home so these are what we call conic
sections intersections of a cone of
light and they relate to orbits and they
relate to the energy that those objects
have now if your space time is flat just
as if your orbit were a parabola it
means the universe the entire universe
possesses zero net total energy think
about that if the shape of the universe
were anything else positively curved or
negatively curved it would not have zero
energy would have negative energy or
positive energy we have zero net total
energy now you wondering is that good or
bad
is actually there's a silver lining to
this what it means is that you can
create the entire universe out of
nothing because nothing has no net
energy associated with it had the
universe been endowed with either
negative or positive energy we'd be
forced to confront
the questions of what was the original
source of energy that begat the universe
and if it had some amount of energy why
is it that amount and not some other
amount the fact that we live in a zero
energy universes bypasses that line of
questioning and does it leave us content
in our emptiness
perhaps but we're no less enlightened by
the ignorance that led to it you know
while all this is going on in the
universe there's something that I think
about often and it's the fact that the
Milky Way the galaxy in which we live is
actually on a collision course with the
nearest large galaxy to us the Andromeda
galaxy in fact pictures of the Andromeda
galaxy or what we use to show what our
Milky Way might look like from the
outside because it's kind of hard to see
what we look like since we're in it all
right we see stars right in front of our
noses we see these gas clouds but the
grand design spiral pattern that spiral
galaxies are so proud of we see that in
the Andromeda we infer that for us okay
so we have several hundred billion stars
in our midst so does the Andromeda
galaxy dromeda galaxy is about two
million light years away and we're on
our way towards each other it is a
collision impending it will be a train
wreck think about it here's every star
in our galaxy attracting every other
star orbiting the center of our galaxy
where there's a supermassive black hole
that system is collide it's falling
towards another system that also has
several hundred billion stars all
attracting each other as they get closer
closer and closer just imagine this
alright
every star feels every other stars
gravity and as they merge with the
motions combined with it
stars get flung his ur and yon there be
stars that will be kicked out of both
systems and will become lost to
intergalactic space
the two black we've got a black hole
they've got a black hole they're gonna
be making a beeline for each other they
will feel each other's effects okay and
if we're not in a direct collision
course even if we're to the side of each
other we will go into orbit around each
other and those black holes will
eventually coalesce and make one bigger
than either one started out to be
eventually our two galaxies will become
one a big fat double galaxy and given
enough time you wouldn't have you would
have no trace that we started out as two
separate systems separated by two
million years two million light years
that is oh by the way a light year is
about 5.8 trillion miles see that's why
we just call them like it's easier all
right here's what's interesting about
that collision these two galaxies we
think galaxies have collided all the
time we see images of galaxies that are
badly disturbed and in the early days of
this exercise we just thought they were
irregular galaxies in fact that was an
official classification for them until
there was an astronomer who said wait a
minute a wrecked this is this exact word
a wrecked Lexus is not a new kind of car
it's just a wrecked Lexus so if you have
a galaxy that's badly disturbed looking
maybe it was an ordinary galaxy that's
in the middle of a collision so we
looked around the universe and we found
galaxies in all stages of collapse
towards each other you can practically
make a timeline of what our collision
with with Andromeda will look like based
on the collection of all the galaxies we
have
out there in the universe that are in
the act of colliding with each other
and so this is in our future the problem
is we will collide with Andromeda after
our son dies after the Sun around which
we orbit expands to become a red giant
and engulfs the orbit of the earth
rendering us a charred ember soon to
become vaporized so we need to find a
way to move to another planet or another
star system to watch this happen but
then when we watch it happen if a star
comes too close you can have a flyby
looting of a flyby looting of the
planets that belong to one star gets
stolen by another because stars will be
flying back and forth so it'll be an
exciting time for Earth when that
happens or it'll be a sight an exciting
time for any civilizations alive to
watch it what we don't know is whether
earth will survive that will we be among
those flung into intergalactic space
will we fall towards the SuperDuper
massive black hole that now occupies its
center or we will we find a new home
around a new star that is perhaps just
born giving us a new lease on life for
the apocalyptic civilization that
follows ours